bon donc bonjour à tous pour commencer
un point d'agenda nous avons aujourd'hui
le président nicolas sarkozy qui est en
déplacement dans l'oise avec une visite
du pôle emploi d'un pôle emploi il
déjeunera ensuite avec des élus et
procédera à une signature de son livre
demain nous aurons notre bureau
politique à huit clos à 18 heures et
mercredi une journée très importante
puisque c'est la journée de travail sur
l'agriculture et la ruralité
cette journée sera introduite par eric
woerth dès 8h30 puis nous aurons des
témoignages d'agriculteurs sur la crise
agricole de l'été crise qui vous le
savez d'ailleurs se poursuit à l'heure
actuelle ensuite trois tables rondes la
première sera sur une véritable vision
d'avenir pour notre agriculture et son
développement
la deuxième table ronde elle aura pour
objet la stratégie européenne pour que
la france retrouve sa première place
dans le monde agricole la troisième
table ronde
elle sera sur les territoires ruraux
pour constituer une priorité pour toute
politique publique
enfin cette matinée sera conclue par un
discours du président nicolas sarkozy
notre président qui par ailleurs devra
aller également pour un nouveau
déplacement vendredi prochain pour une
signature de son livre je passe la
parole à eric pour un poisson aux
élections internes
merci brigitte donc ce week-end se sont
déroulés
nos élections internes qui ont permis le
renouvellement de toutes nos instances
locales présidents de comités
départementaux comités départementaux
délégué de circonscription et en même
temps l'élection des représentants des
militants au conseil national
ces élections locales étaient les
premières depuis 2010 elles ont permis
l'élection de onze mille militants qui
occupent et qui désormais vont occuper
ses différentes fonctions à la fois au
conseil national parlement de notre
mouvement et en même temps dans les
instances de nos fédérations et
notamment dans les comités
départementaux des élections qui se sont
déroulées dans un climat parfaitement
serein et apaisé sans aucune difficulté
donc la première fois que la démocratie
locale au niveau de notre famille
politique et regénérer depuis 2010
auparavant nous avions été dans
l'incapacité pour différentes raisons
d'organiser des élections locales
puisque le mandat des élus qui avaient
été choisis par les militants en 2010
devait s'achever en 2013
compte tenu des difficultés qui sont
apparues après les élections à la
présidence en 2012
ces élections ont été en permanence
reporter d'où les avons organisé de
façon transparente sans aucune
difficulté
donc aujourd'hui c'est un véritable
succès qui a ponctué ces élections je
veux souligner que 102 présidents de
fédérations ont été élus hier 500 hier
et avant-hier 555 délégués de
circonscriptions il y avait 132
candidats pour les présidences de
fédérations il y en avait neuf cent pour
les circonscriptions 660 conseillers
nationaux a été élu et près de 10 mille
élus membres des comités
deux circonscriptions il veut peut dire
je répondrai à vos questions
naturellement si vous en avez sur ces
élections mais 50% des présidents de
fédérations sont des nouveaux présidents
la participation à ces élections a été
supérieure à 40%
nous avons eu qu'une vingtaine de duels
dans des fédérations sur la présidence
sur les délégués de circonscription je
veux le souligner que 50% d'entre eux
ont moins de 50 ans il ya eu donc un
profond renouvellement
voilà en gros les éléments saillants de
ces élections internes qui se sont
parfaitement déroulées je veux souligner
que contrairement à ce qu'on a pu
qu'on pouvait craindre que certains
commentateurs avaient pu évoquer il n'y
a pas eu de tension particulière ni de
compétition particulière qui pourrait
préfigurer les clivages que l'on pourra
peut-être retrouver lors des élections
primaires les enjeux ont été dans la
plupart des cas et dans la quasi
totalité des cas strictement locaux et
les débats qui ont pu avoir lieu dans
quelques fédérations se sont mis en
oeuvre mais en place par rapport à des
débats plutôt locaux donc nous n'avons
pas eu de conflit qui pourrait
préfigurer d'autres débats les élections
sont restés locales dans un climat
serein et apaisé
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous nous
souhaitons mettre l'accent notamment sur
ce point presse sur certainement ce que
détestent le plus les français dans la
vie publique
l'hypocrisie est instrumentalisée au
service d'une personne et cette personne
elle s'appelle christiane taubira nous
venons d'apprendre avec stupeur que
madame taubira loin de s'occuper de son
ministère est de l'intérêt des
justiciables
loin de faire en sorte de contribuer
à ce que le droit progresse dans notre
pays est bien en catimini rédiger un
opuscule pour non pas faire en sorte que
ces idées progressent mais mettre en
place son calendrier de communication
personnels et la démission de lamto bira
n'est pas l'expression d'une sincérité
politique elle est l'expression d'un
plan de com à l'ancienne un plan de com
qui ressemble un petit peu à ce qu'on
faisait il ya une vingtaine d'années je
crée la crise je fais monter la crise je
souhaite la crise pour que la mayonnaise
prenne et puis à l'issue et bien je fais
en sorte d'apparaître comme étant
quelqu'un qui peut en sortir
donc sa diète politique de la posture
politicienne nous la dénonçons
évidemment avec force et nous disons
qu'aujourd'hui
madame taubira est un problème pour
monsieur hollande elle est un problème
qui révélateur d'une chose très
singulière et particulière de la gestion
de françois hollande elle est révélateur
de la faiblesse de monsieur l'an
puisqu'elle a pu faire tout ça puisque
si j'en crois la presse elle lui a même
envoyé son livre le 22 janvier elle a pu
faire tout ça tranquillement sans qu'à
aucun moment
lui n'est un geste un chef un geste de
chefs d'état ne cessent de chef de
gouvernement
celui qui décide elle a pu le faire
tranquillement et aujourd'hui cette
faiblesse
et bien tout simplement elle se
retranscrit au sein de nos institutions
puisque si le simple fait que madame
taubira sorte de ce gouvernement est un
problème pour monsieur hollande et pour
l'ensemble de la gauche et on voit à
quel point ce gouvernement est cette
gauche sont fragiles
aujourd'hui et pour conclure je dirais
que ce gouvernement aujourd'hui est
devenue une auberge espagnole chacun
amène ce qu'il veut mais aucun de
construit un plat qui amène à la france
valérie viens de vous parler de la
situation particulière que l'on vient de
vivre en effet avec madame taubira et je
voudrais dire aussi que sur l'ensemble
de la situation politique en ce moment
il ya il ya urgence
la france est en état d'urgence mais
elle est en état d'urgence pas seulement
sur le plan sécuritaire elle est en état
d'urgence sur le plan économique
je ne devrais pas évidemment l'injure de
vous rappeler les derniers chiffres du
chômage qui ont été annoncés la semaine
dernière
elle est en état d'urgence sociale la
crise agricole sur laquelle guillaume va
revenir ou sur la crise des taxis sur
cette désespérance humaine et nous
sommes aussi en état d'urgence politique
quand une ministre régalienne
en effet comme cela vient d'être appelé
écrit en catimini un livre quand un
projet de loi qui va porter son nom est
en préparation
au-delà de ça aux voix une gauche aux
abois une gauche aux abois qui va
maintenant rentrer après les difficultés
et la sortie de crise bien difficile
pour monsieur valls de la déchéance de
nationalité
s'enfoncer dans les sables mouvants des
primaires les primaires à gauche
c'est le nouveau sujet qui va maintenant
nous occuper
apparemment pendant des semaines après
n'avoir pas su trancher sur la déchéance
de nationalité
on voit que la gauche et le gouvernement
sont en train de se sampler très dense
et dans cette danse et primaires car de
quel primaire s'agit-il
s'agit-il des primaires avec monsieur
hollande ou de primaire sans monsieur
hollande
s'agit-il de primaire alternative au
gouvernement actuel pour une pause et
pour une politique de gauche
ou s'agit-il de primaire qui englobe
l'ensemble on voit bien là difficultés
auxquelles ils sont confrontés et on
voit bien aussi la difficulté de la
ligne politique de ce gouvernement qui
fait qu' il n'apparaît plus évident que
le président sortant soit le président
de la gauche donc suite à ces
atermoiements 7 cette situation va donc
créer un ensemble à nouveau de comment
dirais-je
voilà deux d'interrogations qui vont
évidemment nous poursuivre pendant
longtemps
c'est par ailleurs donc je le disais un
affront une humiliation pour françois
hollande
quand lui-même trouvé naturel en son
temps car président sortant se prête au
jeu des primaires
stéphane le foll l'a rappelé hier dans
une émission pour le moins étonnante où
il de se transformer plus tôt en drh
d'une émission de télévision
quand ministre de l'agriculture soucieux
de régler la crise agricole
il s'étonnait pour lui rappelle
l'engagement du président landes et par
une phrase pour le moins surprenante où
il disait c'était dans l'ambiance de la
campagne que cela avait été dit d'une
j'allais dire d'une tournure de phrase
il leur remettait ça deux côtés comment
ne pas s'étonner après que les français
s'éloigne du monde politique
quand un engagement de campagne par le
porte parole même du gouvernement et mis
ainsi de côté donc ce climat est bien
évidemment nous allons pouvoir le détail
est avec vous de manière plus précise et
tout d'abord concernant justement l'une
des crises dont je vous parlais à
l'instant qui est la crise agricole et
guillaume va vous en parler avant la
crise agricole
pardon les suite de la démission de
christiane taubira
il faut solder le passif de biran est
aujourd'hui au nom des républicains avec
eric ciotti avec valérie de bord avec
brigitte kuster
je veux lancer un appel au nouveau garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice jean
jacques urvoas
ça servirait à rien de changer le
titulaire de la place vendôme
si la même politique était poursuivi on
appelle donc jean jacques urvoas à
solder le passif des années taubira est
donc très concrètement à engager dès
maintenant le réarmement pénale et
pénitentiaire de la france et pour cela
nous lui demandons 4 rupture 4
rupture par rapport aux années de bien
premièrement nous appelons jean jacques
urvoas à rétablir les peines plancher
pour les délinquants récidivistes et les
auteurs de violences deuxièmement nous
appelons jean jacques urvoas à préparer
l'abrogation de la loi taubira du 15
août 2014 sur la contrainte pénale la
contrainte pénale qui consiste defacto à
supprimer les peines de prison pour
certains délits contraintes pénale qui
sera étendue au 1er janvier 2017 à
l'ensemble des délits
d'où l'urgence d'abroger dès maintenant
la loi taubira de 2014 pour éviter que
dans quelques mois au 1er janvier 2017
l'ensemble des délits ne soit en réalité
quasiment plus punie de peines de prison
deuxième rupture la troisième rupture
que nous attendons et que nous évoquons
ce matin pour que jean jacques urvoas le
nouveau mise de la justice nous
répondent nous l'appelons à abandonner
le projet de réforme de la justice des
mineurs
comme vous le savez dans les cartons de
la chancellerie
il ya ce projet de réforme de la justice
des mineurs qui est extrêmement
dangereux avec notamment la suppression
des tribunaux correctionnels pour
mineurs ceux qui jugent les mineurs de
16 à 18 ans pour des délits punis depuis
deux trois ans résident ils s'adonnent à
des actes de violence graves
nous appelons jean jacques urvoas a
indiqué très clairement à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat que ce projet
taubira de réforme de justice des
mineurs est désormais abandonné
quatrième rupture à laquelle nous
appelons le nouveau mis de la justice
c'est l'instauration d'un vrai plan
d'urgence pour les prisons il nous
paraît absolument indispensable que le
nouveau garde des sceaux décide de l'
isolement des détenus radicaliser non
seulement par rapport aux autres détenus
mais aussi isolement les uns des autres
à cet égard avec eric ciotti avec
georges fenech nous avons fait des
propositions très précises à l'assemblée
nationale que christiane taubira avait
écarté nous appelons jean jacques urvoas
à s'en saisir
isolement des détenus radicaliser
création d'un vrai service de
renseignement pénitentiaire intégrée à
la communauté du renseignement
ça peut paraître technique mais est
absolument fondamentale jean jacques
urvoas avait été le rapporteur de la loi
sur le renseignement
j'en étais le co-rapporteur nous avions
essayé contre l'avis de christiane
taubira à l'assemblée nationale de créer
un vrai service de renseignement
pénitentiaire ça n'avait pas pu
prospérer parce que christiane taubira
s'y est opposée maintenant que jean
jacques urvoas et garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice il lui appartient
de créer ce service de renseignement
pénitentiaire intégrée à la communauté
du renseignement c'est-à-dire coopérants
de manière effective et juridiquement
très cadré avec les services
d'espionnage et de contre espionnage des
ministères de l'intérieur et des
ministères de la défense dans le cadre
de ce plan d'urgence pour les prisons
nous appelons également jean jacques
urvoas a lancé un vrai programme de
construction de vingt mille places de
prison supplémentaires
je rappelle qu'on a environ soixante
sept mille détenus en france pour 57
mille places de prison ça n'est pas un
problème de surpopulation carcérale
c'est un problème de sous capacités
pénitentiaires
lorsqu'on veut bien se rappeler qu'il y
à 97 milles places de prison au royaume
uni et 77 mille places de prison en
allemagne
voilà rétablissement des peines
planchers abrogation de la loi taubira
2014 sur la contrainte pénale abandon du
projet de réforme de la justice des
mineurs et instauration d'un vrai plan
d'urgence pour les prisons ce sont les
quatre rupture qui nous paraissent
nécessaires et nous appelons très
solennellement le nouveau garde des
sceaux à solder le passif des années
taubira
jean jacques urvoas lorsqu'il a pris ses
fonctions il ya quelques jours a dit
qu'il avait 15 mois devant lui
c'est l'évidence du calendrier il faut
que ces 15 mois soit utile la france ne
peut pas attendre il faut en urgence
réparer les erreurs commises par
christiane taubira voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire brigitte kuster
m'inciter à vous parler d'agriculture
j'y viens premier point était assez
différent des questions agricoles mais
le point sur l'agriculture est tout à
fait tout à fait majeur il ya
aujourd'hui on le perçoit vraiment sur
le terrain
une colère de la france rurale une
exaspération du monde agricole et une
détresse des habitants des territoires
ruraux mercredi matin au siège des
républicains il y aura tout un temps de
débat d' analyse de propositions sur ces
questions de l'agriculture et du leurre
de la ruralité organisé par eric woerth
en charge du projet des républicains et
président sarkozy s'exprimera à spa vers
12h30 il dit mercredi sur ces questions
d'ores et déjà avec eric comme
parlementaire je veux souligner notre
totale incompréhension à l'égard de
l'attitude de stéphane le foll sur le
projet de loi sur la proposition de loi
pardon relatives à la compétitivité de
l'agriculture que les sénateurs
républicains ont adopté voici quelques
semaines et qui vient devant nous à
l'assemblée nationale jeudi
donc je dis on a un rendez vous avec
stéphane le foll dans l'hémicycle sur
nos propositions et on veut que le
ministre de l'agriculture nous explique
pourquoi il s'oppose non pas seulement à
un ou deux articles mais à tous les
articles
toutes les propositions que nous faisons
qui sont des propositions de bon sens
qui ont été travaillés évidemment en
liaison avec la profession agricole
je pense
la nécessité d'une meilleure
contractualisation c'est à dire une
intégration des coûts de production dans
les contrats agricoles
je pense à la question technique mais
extrêmement importante de la cession à
titre onéreux des contrats laitiers
je pense à l'information du consommateur
sur l'origine des viandes et des
produits laitiers je pense à la
déduction pour investissement et la
déduction pour aléas c'est-à-dire
mécanisme au fond fiscale
d'amortissement des aléas marchés pour
protéger les agriculteurs qu'il s'agisse
des céréaliers ou des éleveurs
je pense aussi à notre proposition
d'allègement des procédures
d'autorisation sur les installations
d'élevage
nous proposons très concrètement d'avoir
aucune norme s'additionnant s'ajoutant
aux normes européennes
je pense aussi à notre proposition
d'allègement des charges patronales des
entreprises agricoles de plus de 20
salariés permanents jusqu'à 1,5 fois le
salaire minimum
bref on a une douzaine de mesures très
concrètes qui serait un véritable ballon
d'oxygène pour les agriculteurs et
notamment pour les éleveurs laitiers
comme éleveur viande des mesures très
concrètes un véritable ballon d'oxygène
et nous appelons stéphane le foll a
écouté les propositions de l'opposition
ici nous sommes le parti des solutions
on est un parti d'opposition non propose
aussi des solutions ici au siège des
républicains et au parlement il faut que
le gouvernement entende c'est ses
propositions et ne soit pas dans la
posture politicienne refusant de
débattre et refusant ce qui serait un
progrès immédiats pour le monde agricole
j'ajoute que nos propositions qui sont
très concrète et très opérationnelle
contraste avec les voeux pieux exprimé
par stéphane le foll
lorsque stéphane le foll hier matin
déclare qu'ils souhaitent
je le cite souhaite la levée des
sanctions à l'endroit de la russie c'est
très bien d'exprimer des souhaits
m'enfin c'est
ministre donc c'est au gouvernement
français d'obtenir c'est au gouvernement
de gouverner il n'est pas là pour
commenter pour souhaiter pour manifesté
des envies des intentions non ils sont
là pour gouverner
et comme gouverne très mal va nous nous
sommes en propositions non pas pour les
aider eux c'est pas notre sujet mais
pour aider le monde agricole qui
aujourd'hui encore une fois est en
grande détresse et qui attend du
parlement des décisions immédiates pour
soulager leurs souffrances et pour leur
redonner des marges de compétitivité
on a une agriculture exportatrice on a
des talents on a de l'énergie on a des
savoir faire mais on a aussi des boules
et réglementaires normatif qui sont
attachés au pied des agriculteurs et
notamment des éleveurs
cette proposition de loi des
républicains elle apporte des solutions
il faut vraiment que le gouvernement les
regarde de très près parce que dès jeudi
on peut les adopter c'est pas des
projets pour 2010 est pour 2020 ou pour
la saint glinglin non c'est directement
opérationnels dès jeudi
on peut avoir des mesures utiles pour le
monde agricole que nous proposons ici au
siège des républicains